évidemment la réforme de retraites qui
dans ce contexte est une réforme qui
s'impose et marge de manœuvre que nous
avons c'est dans notre capacité à
travailler plus longtemps nous allons
nous opposer de manière frontale à la
réforme des retraites d'abord parce que
encore une fois les gens qui nous
dirigent mis la situation économique du
pays dans des conditions compliquées
François Bayrou allié de renaissance
lance un pavé dans la mare sur le sujet
du moment la réforme des retraites je
suis opposée au passage en force si l'on
veut que la réforme des retraites
prennent tout son sens et qu'elle soit
acceptée
bien il faut conduire la conduire selon
une méthode je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'on se laisse enfermer sur un débat de
forme personne veut un passage en forme
fort sur cette réforme des retraites et
ensuite rétro pédaler souvenez-vous à
l'entre-deux-tours parce que j'imagine
qu'à ce moment-là
si vous voulez proposer parce que
j'imagine qu'il essayait d'envoyer des
signaux à la gauche pour espérer obtenir
un meilleur score au second tour face à
Marine Le Pen on va faire
mûrir ces réformes avec toutes les
forces économiques et sociales
Bayrou a raison de dire que il y aura
pas de passage en force et il y en aura
pas et il y aura des bas parlementaires
il faut pas qu'on aille tous plus vite
que la musique avant de parler du
comment il faut qu'on parle du quoi il y
a des concertations le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft demain reçoit de
nouveau les partenaires sociaux il se
trouve que c'est moi qui porte cette
réforme sous l'autorité de la première
ministre et du président de la
République donc son avis jamais je me
permettrais de dire ça et son avis
compte comme celui de tous les autres il
y en a beaucoup
il y a des procédures qui sont ouvertes
aujourd'hui toutes les hypothèses sont
ouvertes si ils décident de passer par
le pdfss nous serons en opposition
frontale quelle que soit la mesure
contenue dans le
PLFSS c'est donc de mettre un amendement
sur les retraites au sein du projet de
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
c'est pas forcément en octobre que ça
passera l'assemblée ça peut être en
octobre comme ça peut être au printemps
ça reste ouvert en octobre évidemment
c'est ouvert parce que nous nous
respectons le rythme de la discussion et
le rythme de la concertation les 8
petits enfants de la souveraine ont
veillé son cercueil William et Harry en
tête suivi notamment des princesses
Béatrice et Eugénie les filles d'androux
un moment solennel pendant lequel la
foule a continué à défiler en silence au
fond de cette rue un bâtiment vient de
s'effondrer
oh mon dieu ce n'est pas possible mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe
nous sommes au sud de Taïwan tout près
de l'épicentre du tremblement de terre
l'élu de la France insoumise a fait
savoir qu'il se mettait en retrait de
ses fonctions coordinateurs du parti
Adrien catenin ça a été visé par une
main courante d'épouser déposée par son
épouse après une dispute à Taïwan les
dégâts sont importants des trains
renversés une gare en partie détruite et
un pont autoroutier sectionné en son
centre
il a reconnu les violences commises sur
sa femme et au sujet de cette main
courante elle aurait été dévoilée
publiquement alors que la principale
concernée ne le souhaitait pas il les a
reconnu donc contact parce que c'est pas
si courant que ça les personnes qui
reconnaissent les violences n'ont pas
qu'il l'a fait maintenant il doit se
mettre en retrait de vraiment de toute
parole politique c'est pas possible bon
c'est vrai que de manière générale la
gauche nous a souvent habitué à avoir de
très belles postures morales sur le
féminisme et on se rend compte et on l'a
vu à plusieurs occasions et je passe pas
spécifiquement de cette affaire que les
les mots et les postures ne suivaient
pas toujours dans la vie et dans les
relations avec les femmes de fait Adrien
catenin va être en retrait il a pris une
décision qui est une décision courageuse
même du groupe et je pense même du
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale mais je
on verra on verra là écoutez il y a un
communiqué qui est sorti il y a 1h enfin
laissez-nous un peu le temps de nous
organiser de discuter entre nous et il a
reçu ce matin le soutien de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Adrien décide de tout prendre
sur lui je salue sa dignité et son
courage et lui redit ma confiance et mon
affection fin de citation